good morning everyone welcome to the
morning session
um yeah so we have three talks uh this
morning uh with a half an hour break
after the first one
and I'm actually quite looking forward
to a
an interesting discussion based on the
title of the talk uh so Karen sagala
will give us a road back for the next
phase of such research please got it all
right thank you very much
good morning everyone
and there's going to be somewhat
different
ly a very technical talk
maybe uh policy talk of sorts
um I give you a pragmatic problem
solving approach
right it's different from
you know other ways of doing research
and I've heard uh several conjectures
yesterday
from various speakers I I want to make a
conjecture over here
and the conjecture is if a human created
it designed it then we ought to be able
to analyze it okay just keep that in
mind as we go through this and just to
see how many friendly faces are in the
audience everyone just ask how many of
you use yourselves as a true theoretic
types yeah
proof theoretic you know people who do
Theory
proof Theory okay
okay
how many of you are kind of uh Geeks Who
just code and do
programs right solvers okay
okay and what about the rest of you
you're neither of these two groups why
are you here okay
um
so
I think somewhat I'm gonna say I've said
it before but it didn't kind of make
much impact
um and some what I'm gonna say it may
sound harsh but it's not meant to be you
know kind of offensive to anybody in
person it's just that I'm really
concerned about where we are with this
you know field right and so it's meant
to set a conversation about how we can
bring the theory people can be empirical
people together to actually work
together we've been meeting like this
for a number of years maybe 10 years or
so and every time the theory people can
talk to themselves the implementers talk
to themselves and there is no
communication between the two so I might
not have the right answer here which is
fine you know we can you know corner be
in the in the break and tell me that you
know I'm you know full of it but I think
I have an idea of how we can make this
work okay
now this is a success story and a very
unlikely collaboration with uh Armand
biri who has written I don't know how
many solvers he has written so far
anybody has a count of how many solvers
he has written
dozens right okay and me who has who
I've not written any solvers okay I
didn't write any problems so I'm neither
a coder nor a theorist I don't know what
happened it's just a random crank right
um so I want to acknowledge both Armand
and his postdoc Matthias who should be
on Zoom
um and you know when there is a chance
for them to kind of speak up we let them
talk and I'm also uh gonna acknowledge
who are not my students they took my
class on formal verification I became
very interested in sad and they're
volunteering to kind of help with what
I'm going to show you
okay so here is kind of what we're going
to talk about I'm going to give you a
little brief history of cdcl that's my
own brief history because I know some
things that happened that probably
nobody else knows then I'm gonna talk
about the transition the phase
transition hoopla if you don't know what
that is I'll mention that in a few
minutes
and then I'm gonna give an attempt to
explain the performance of cdcl
they'll talk about the set competition
it's uh
Brian
I'm going to talk about this at
competition
um and then I'm gonna talk about okay
skip this one uh a prototype that Arman
uh developed called tabular asset and
then give you just a sense of what we
can do that we're not doing right now
okay
so the unintended birth of grasp how
many of you have grass came up came
about
how did it actually happen right this is
how it happened
I'm an electrical engineer okay I solve
problems I don't do Siri I like Mass but
I like the mask that helps me solve
problems
so we were doing we had a big project
called timing analysis okay
um we had chips that we needed to know
that it run at you know 500 megahertz
back then it was kind of a big deal 500
megahertz and so you get a circuit like
this and you say Okay assume units delay
on all of the gates
um I wiggle this input here how long
does it take to reach the outfit Z okay
it's a you know traditional problem in
critical path uh methods you know you
can just say each one of those gets a
delay block and what is the longest path
here seven seven okay so we go I can go
like this and I can say one to zero here
goes one to zero over there
that was what we were doing
that is an invisible path why is it in
feasible
well because when we ignored the logic
you know it was feasible but if we allow
the logic to be taken into account
meaning if I have to go from X1 to a
um X2 must be zero otherwise it will
block it right there's an or gate here
if you want to go from A to B
I have to have x equals one otherwise it
will block it here because the zero on
this input would block the transition
and so on and so forth you can go
through this right
and you get to
this gate now to go from D to E
I gotta have X1 I'm sorry X3 being zero
otherwise this this or gate would lock
it but X3 is already one so we have an
inconsistency there is an inconsistency
on the stats so this test is called
default space okay that means the
longest possible delay for pass delay of
this accounting for logical constraints
is six
okay so we knew this there's a lot of uh
discussion in the cat Community about
you know false passive circuits and so
on so forth and then
um
I had a big project that was doing
low-level analysis of these we're
looking at the transistor inside these
things and you know how the wires and
all of that stuff and then I had this
discussion with a very smart PhD student
Circa 1994.
for accurate time analysis we need to
check the logical consistency of circuit
paths we need a set solver
what did I know about Sarasota back then
not much I knew that you know uh the
West Coast case complexity is it
Financial I knew about P naught equal to
p uh what did I say it wrong P not equal
to MP
and I said okay
um go get yourself a set solver so let's
finish this project
so then no existing search solver can
schedule our problem size they may
possibly handle 50 variables or circuits
have between 10 000 to 100 000 Gates
which means variables and now he's
telling the he's gonna go from 50 to 100
000 right we spent a year arguing okay
because my report to NSF has to be about
you know we found the longest pass in a
chip and this guy is doing something
else
well
as well that ends well right
he won
um so I said what do you suggestion
instead he said we need to develop our
own solver and I said you gotta be
kidding right okay in the end he said we
can do it and then after that argument
for a year Grace was born okay that's
how grass came about
I can't think of any other way that this
would have happened maybe another group
Another Universe would have come up with
something like this but I created this
problem for forcing us to think about
how to scale solving these large CNF
formulas if what the difference by the
way after this we were flush with cash
and to give us a lot of money to find
Long uh false passing their chips we
found tons of them none of them were the
longest so so this killer app which
triggered the development of this was
really not that important after that
okay then it became something more
important for other applications right
that's how it came
uh here's his dissertation you know the
papers and and all of that stuff
and then so this was in 1995 1996. in
2000 how many of you remember the phase
transition phenomenon
yeah yeah this was on the Evening News
you know journalists who had nothing to
do and I think we're trying to
understand what set is right and the
idea was that when you have random three
set instances where you very you know so
you create uniform formulas you know
with random uh uh three Set uh Clauses
and you plot the runtime they were using
uh DPL back then against the close to
variable ratio they discovered something
like physics
the quality phase transition fewer
constraints per variable means the
problem is easily satisfiable
many more constraints than variables the
problem is easily unsatisfiable and then
at the 4.25 magically the problems
become extremely hard
well become interested in that we
plotted close to variable ratio against
what we were doing with grass and circus
and we found a scatter plot it wasn't
doing that so we went to
the 2000 Workshop in in the Netherlands
to understand what's going on right so
that's why Paulo that's me and I found
out this is Armin so we're all there you
know a little younger and maybe
less wise
um and we told them that then
that um when we did the close to
variable ratio in our instances that
there was no correlation and it should
be obvious in retrospect I mean we're
not you know doing random random
formulas these formulas describe
circuits that have some structure so I
started talking about the structure we
need to understand the structure the
structure of the formula what's the
structure of the formula
now this is a quick summary of now what
happened next so we had grasp uh 1996
Sato and this is all documented
uh uh took what we did in close learning
and Incorporated it into their solver
okay and then they introduced this head
tail thing for propagation which then
was taken by chaff which said we'll do
in close learning like grass and we
improved on the head tail Thing by doing
this to watch literal thing then all of
this got included in mini set this is
2003 where it also implemented basically
chef and grass and also took some of the
other stuff that we did which is uh like
incremental solving and also through the
bullying
this is what has been called cdcl
I disagree with that because I think we
don't give enough credit to chat
um you see uh grass introduce close
learning by the way the guy who called
coined cdcl is by the name Florence Ryan
and his dissertation from Simon treasure
and um it doesn't capture everything you
see uh grass had a very aggressive
branching strategy that's called delis
Dynamic largest something something at
every stage of the search it finds the
literal that will satisfy the most
unresolved Clauses it was going for
satisfying the most clauses
uh chaff said no no no no we're gonna
try and uh branch on conflicts
you know promote variables that appear
in conflicts and I like to call that
conflict driven branching there is a
theme over here the theme is conflict
driven satisfiability is a combination
of conflict driven learning and conflict
driven branching everything else is just
variations on the theme so my
understanding of what is now
unfortunately we have to keep calling
cdcl but it's really the combination of
these two is that a conflict driven set
solver aggressively attempts to falsify
the formula and when it fails it
produces a satisfying assignment
that's what it is okay
now why does this work
I still don't know and I dare anybody in
this room to tell me how they know that
right and by the way we're gonna get to
that
um the theoretical complexity stuff that
has been established only talks about
close learning and assumes that the
branching is done and some you know way
that you know we make the proof books
right but I really think there is
something to this you know this is an
approach to solving that says let's
aggressively falsify the formula
and then when we fail we find a solution
okay
there might be other ways to do this
right but this one seems to work and I
don't think that we have a satisfactory
answer for why
um
this is from 2011 again I presented data
and nobody paid attention Okay this is
this is we took a thousand instances and
different families and so on and we said
okay let's understand you know the big
picture so this is dpll it kind of
stopped at about 200
when we added closed learning but with
this aggressive satisfying uh branching
curves that you know we kind of pushed
it up this is a qualitative Improvement
right it's not like one percent or five
percent or you know two more results
and then if we just do branching on
conflicts we do a little bit we do we do
well quite a bit but not as much as
close learning you combine the two and
that's what I would hold CD said you
know if that's
hard to say CD said just it's Comfort
driven solving conflict driven solving
is what is going on over here okay
and the uh connective tissue between
growth learning and uh conflict driven
branching is this fast propagation
that's enabled by two to watch networks
because you would learn these long
Clauses and you need to have actually
have a quick way of figuring out if the
Clause becomes unicorn this to me is
you know what we have today everything
that happened since then is just
I don't know noise
that's that's my harsh it's noise okay
why do they work so well okay
consider this
this is I uh thank you I read the
chapter
not in detail but I found nice quotes in
it right so a cdcl solver uh this is
reporting result that was done by uh
their wish and and Albert you know
saying that cdcl solver unit propagation
close learning treatment research
research had to be included in improving
this but not branching
can establish unsatisfiability over CNN
formula in time polynomial in the
shortest resolution replication of that
formula very nice result very nice
result
the empirical observation is ctcl
solvers routinely establish
unsatisfiability of very large see and a
formulas that encode human created
artifacts Hardware software so something
that came from somebody's head
conclusion
these large formulas must have short
resolution refutations
but why
maybe because they have some
recognizable structural attributes
okay
so in the space of all Sienna formulas
out there there is Advantage benefit
small number that come from somebody's
head not they don't think CNF but
they're designing something and then
gets encoded in CNS and then it's easy
and the question is
can we actually infer that can we know
what the intention was in in producing
these things
um so looking back at the first
transition which I kind of I mean we
were almost stepped out of the room you
know that that Workshop was full of
theoreticians who were not satisfied
with 4.25 close per variable closest for
variable would make it very difficult
but they were kind of having a big you
know magnifying glass on that and saying
it's no it's 4.13752 and this is a waste
of time okay a waste of time so
but but one thing stuck to me later is
that The Closer variable ratio of random
three set can be viewed as a structural
metric that is predictive of the either
difficulty of solving the formula using
dpll so they Define the class of
formulas okay they're not very
interesting from packet perspective but
the class of formulas they could
actually correlate runtime with
something that has to do with the
structure of the formula was random the
question here to me is do large
non-random formulas encoding human
created artifacts have structural
metrics another CV ratio perhaps of
random three set maybe a bit more
sophisticated than that
are these easy to compute
um if we can find them are they
predictable is the difficulty of solving
the formulas using cdcl okay these are
open questions and I would say that the
invention of grass was a stroke of a lot
here because if we did not have that
application which provided us with very
quick Solutions then I would not be at
the Simons Institute today I mean it's
just it's a fact that um it base just
happened magically to have these short
refutations for some reason
conjecture because I am not smart enough
to a lot of people in this room who can
actually do this much better than I
um it was basically a circuit set
problem you know we had Gates that have
two inputs and so the Sienna Clause had
two-thirds of the Clauses being binary
and one said the internally that's not
enough to kind of make it you know go
fast but somehow the constraints were
very special a lot of locality okay
uh there are some proof theoretic stuff
on circuit set you know that I think
people can talk about that you know
maybe that we can explain then why these
things that come from circuits you know
are easy solve or not right
um uh
there's a a a a colleague who I lost
track of if anybody knows where Carson
sense is he would draw these beautiful
you know I mean nothing growing he has a
foot to generate these these are
pictures of Santa formulas right
actually they still put them as kind of
a little icon in the uh set competition
you know I have more of them because I
in 2011 we had the circumference at
Michigan and I asked him to please send
me these beautiful formulas we suck when
we come to kind of Market ourselves you
know because we're so kind of boring so
when we have these nice pictures I had
them run on a loop you know in the uh
were you there 2011 and so you know
students would come in and look at
school because my colleagues in the
department you know have more sexy stuff
to put on things you know so I I you
know this is nice this is nice this is
not they're a structure right there is
structure okay ah okay
that's a new set
it's that competition
I stole some slides from a couple of uh
set compositions I pulled this one from
2021 and it yeah
do I have a characterization no this is
open I'm asking for people to start
thinking about this
it's a plea please okay so uh you know
the the purpose of competition are
stated over here they're very clear
compilation of new challenging
backgrounds okay
promotion of self solvers and their
development
to which audience I don't know
evaluation of character app solver
snapshot
good
um
and then
um this is now from but it's still 2021.
okay we received almost 1100 submissions
instances uh after we eliminated the
notice
if some by many sat within one minute
then it's easy we don't care about it
right so 952 uh 352 went into the main
track for 600 into the crypto track
then um for the uh
main track we use 400 you know I mean
you can see all of this okay and we did
you know we we selected a bunch of
benchmarks
and then
the Assumption over here is that really
set is our reference and what we're
doing comparing is anything that can
happen so every Improvement is after
that because if you remove cbcl and CD
branching nothing works
nothing works
okay so where theory and practice parted
ways what at that point where again
quote from the uh beautiful complexity
chapter it is still mostly an open
problem to establish theoretical results
about how to commonly used see this
algorithm
heuristics contribute or sometimes fail
to contribute to the success of cdca
church
so the practitioners are busy just
competing with each other to beat the
next guy with I sold one more than you
and the theoreticians are left behind I
mean you've got nothing to do with this
absolutely nothing
because it's impossible you couldn't
even do branching as part of your uh Pro
theoretic investigations
so
what I'm saying here is that yeah I said
business okay she can do we sits even
you know how can you do uh the umpteen
other options that they have I I spoke
at the Kev in 2014 and Armin was sitting
next to me in a panel and I was going on
like five slides the various settings
for his lingerling solver
my problem is I stopped understanding
anything that's happening in the field I
don't understand anything
and then here is what happens with the
competition okay we run this competition
and um that that Top Line here is for
the virtual best solver if any solver
solve the problem then add it from there
but you look at all of the other solvers
and they are come together they're just
you know they're statistically
insignificant
yes
or based on
they're all based on key set or caticle
so the others are what
okay
dude I mean you might be actually making
my points
um
so I think so I it doesn't work okay it
doesn't doesn't matter
um
we have also plots with the winners of
of every year uh on the same competition
set right and you really see that every
year there is progress what what are
these plots
okay stay tuned I I have answers for
every question here
I prepared okay so stay tuned okay yeah
okay so so my point is my point is
um you know just showing
who sort of tell many is not enough we
need to deep go deeper
uh can you explain this one okay this is
not only a Kitsap or something like this
or is it but there is kind of a gap
between these two groups here and
there's no explanation we yes
I mean there is an explanation okay
so actually this well you said last time
that there is noise between this and
everything that happened actually this
explanation is very clear the difference
is whether you use the local search
solver or not
and SLS local search solver and we used
well I use the uh I mean use some
version of you also somebody I actually
used box set because I couldn't use
armin's work but so that's the clear
separation here that's the the three
things up there or the four things up
there that's local search everything
below no local search so that's actually
one of the things that is in noise
there's like maybe two more I will say
but but local search is very significant
and that nothing solvent unset problems
it does actually help even for onset I'm
not going to argue oh it's longer here
we can talk about that okay if you've
convinced me that we can use local
search for the large instances that we
create for verification then then you
know I'm I'm willing to say you know I'm
wrong so um you showed a plot it earlier
DPL versus cdco yeah
those instances today are much easier
for many of these solvers so if you no
hold on if you compare grasp against the
the latest solvers there's not
competition it's 20 years of you know
development of solvers right so I mean
so what so what point you're making yeah
is you are just saying that you know
everything since then is noise that that
doesn't hold up no no I'm just going to
show you that on Mini set today you know
which is competing with things that are
happening today
if you can come up with a solver that
can do all instances equally well
well that would go against the grain of
the the okay the hardness of the problem
itself all right
let me finish
because I have
Amazon
for you to go forward because you guys
are not doing science
this is a very bold statement and I'm
gonna tell you why it's it's yes
I don't understand the evolution of the
competitions but uh
you know when I was familiar with it 10
years ago it was the
portfolio's albums who were winning the
competition because they would choose
for each problem uh uh uh weak solver
they wanted to use so so is portfolio
sort of excluded from these competitions
I don't know I mean some of the
competitions have portfolios tracks
right right but what my point is that we
can do the competition and we can figure
out you know but we don't understand
here's my next slide
uh the annual competition setup okay
an arbitrary collection of benchmarks
they might have a scheme for doing
defense arbitrary
an auditor collection of Black Box
solvers now here's the thing and the
last competition there were 39 solvers
they may be all based on cassette or
something like that but I don't know
what's inside them
and then they go through this a rather
continuously changing competition rules
and then Armin wins
how is that science
okay okay so the competition is about
winning
I'm saying research about understanding
and explaining and that's what has been
missing
I sit in this set competition or in set
you know conferences and people talk
about stuff and I'm lost I'm no I'm not
the smartest guy in the room but you
know this can't be you know the way that
we do research
so can we go research please
can we do research
okay research in the Natural Sciences
astronomy particle physics whatever okay
they have data collection that's
extremely expensive
telescope space probes particle
colliders they the community you know
spends a lot of dollars kind of on
instruments that collect data they
collect the data
then they create the data they put it in
widely accessible persistent databases
that's available to all the scientists
then the scientists go and you know
access the data and they do research in
the data they find patents in the data
they come up with new things in the data
and the results produce the energy sets
that are
can be checked by any other researcher
to confirm it
and competition is not about winning
there's nothing to win over here it's
about who is the first to discover
something new and interesting in the
data
okay yes
even though I'm not sure maybe I can
make a comment so sure so I think I
think sort of the point is a bit off
because
we have the conference for Science and
the competition is not about science and
you're making the claim that that the
sub Community is
is doing science through the competition
or claiming to do or science but it's
the competition is not about science
science really I agree but I think it
has
negatively affected doing the science in
that certain Community okay so let's
let's talk about results research in the
unnatural computer science
okay
and I'm not this is
I put some slides way back uh from uh uh
UC Berkeley Professor uh which I'm gonna
make name talking about uh the
scientific method and the computer
scientific method right so I'm gonna
just focus on set
we have very cheap data generation we
control everything we choose the
Benchmark we choose the solvers which is
what we collect which is so we decide
what
what the data is it's not like we have a
you know somebody looking to be heavens
and figuring out what comes out we we
create we create the data
then we do not curate the data why
because it's not interesting not worth
the effort okay you may disagree but
hang on data analysis why bother the
data will change next year and anyway
who cares you know about repeatability
and the competition is my solver so one
more than the other one
geeky game show yes
I have a comment I think it's even worse
it's also created based on what current
solvers can do
yeah so data is skewed towards yeah
technology yeah so so we might Overlook
some ideas that otherwise would have
some magnetic you know if we don't do
this
so
oh nothing say say whatever it is
okay I I ten years ago we had a
discussion about this actually a few and
me
um and I agree to some extent that this
is not science but at the same time the
other option is that you do exploratory
data analysis and try to understand what
is going on just like in physics just
like in math okay
so I have a proposal for her to do that
that sounds great because I've been
working a lot on that and it's just a
lot of work by the way no results I I
told Ironman this might be a hustle
audience
um and this is not just a one one so
he's gonna be at the set conference in
uh in in July and I said you know find
if we can find uh at some time at the
conference where we can get a lot of
people kind of talking about this you
know I think we have it's not me it's
not arminus you know everybody would
have to kind of pitch in to do it let me
show you what the proposal is I'm saying
it's an alternative that's what I'd like
but since I'm not gonna win a compliment
to the competition right let's do at
least that
okay we need to organize the Declaration
okay
um we need to figure out families of
formulas I'm going to show you some
examples
the share setting attributes right we're
going to agree on a single example
solver that can be the code base for
trying different options you know to
figure out what's going on in science
you change one thing at a time you don't
do you know everything at the same time
and and and then expect that you're
gonna learn something you're not going
to learn anything from that
um and perform experiments that measure
some performance Network whatever it is
when a single configuration is varied
across a specific range and here is kind
of and then periodata by making it
accessible one of the problems with the
competition is every year is separate
it's like a silo of data that we can't
really kind of uh look at and analyze uh
later so
we need to do that and then this is kind
of where I think we can bring some
collaboration between two routines and
practitioners four teams of
theoreticians and practitioners to carry
out deep analysis
of the data to tease out statistically
significant performance correlations
between specific attributes of CNF
families and corresponding solver
configurations okay
okay because we need to stop saying my
solar is better than your software we
need to talk about what the solver
actually does okay so if your software
is the message we're going to take it as
the base and we're going to do that
but the problem is is that right there
uh there is an issue because depending
on your choice of the
single so-called single extensible
solver and you can get very different
conclusions we have to figure out how to
do that so in the brief I asked the uh
Clark how many smt solvers are there
and he mentioned about half a dozen
major Supply
how many subscribers do we have so far
hundreds
that makes no sense
it makes no sense because you cannot do
science with 100 different things that
you have no idea you're not even the one
who created them knows what they're
doing I mean at least admitted to I
don't know why I did that right so don't
pretend that we're doing science please
don't pretend that we're doing science
we're doing we are competing on I am
gonna beat you competition it's not
science
okay this is a massive undertaking that
requires buy-in from the intact
Community but it holds the promise of
immigrating the field fostering
substantive collaboration that enrich
both theory and practice outside of this
community nobody knows what the heck is
happening against that solvers nobody
outside our community
no not not true
you know what circuit
and what in the circuit that you've
designed why it performs efficiently
let's talk about a multiple
microprocessor without the execution I
think there's a lot more
audience but not from you
I thought I liked you and I'm always a
friendly guys
um yeah so although there are there are
things I uh so the competition has been
mostly to be a real kind of more
objective measurement of what is the
current state of the art and so I have
plots to show that every year there's
progress and we also in the competition
reports we show we argue why we think
that the the progress happen what are
the techniques that contributed that all
these offers in the next year are adding
but so I do think that such an
alternative uh competition is a good
thing okay challenge is only how to get
those families right because okay all
these theoretical families right that uh
there are many many partitions yes uh
practice people are not interested in
and but we do not know how to get good
families but we should we should we
should try doing that I mean that's
that's my point I think Marshall has
also been arguing for this for a decade
yes but
the fact that it's difficult to do
doesn't mean we shouldn't try and keep
trying that's it that's all that's all
I'm saying
Randy
so on your point about the uh a common
platform I'll disagree with it in the
following sense I think the better is
actually what's out there now so
actually there's three solvers out there
that count for anything that's keysight
catechol and mini set meaning everyone
who does work now is building on that
code fairly directly and the fact that
all these solvers in the competition
have to make their code available
afterwards kind of keeps people just
grafting in the latest update so the
code is actually remarkably similar
across solvers
I claim that's a better
even though it's sort of chaotic
anarchic
blah blah blah but trying to get a bunch
of people to sit down say this shall be
our solver and this is the API is going
to be uh first of all impossible and
second of all just cause everything to
stagnate okay I think that argue for
that more okay uh evolutionary approach
that actually exists right now three is
okay you know 40 is not that's what I'm
saying there's there's three yeah tell
me another one that's worth worrying
about right now
two hands
out of all those four cryptomani said
not that I want to like promote my own
solver but it's the only one that
actually has the capability to Output
the data that you're actually talking
about right yeah it can output gigabytes
of data then you know run it through the
proof system connect the proof to the to
this to the actual behavior of the
solver and actually learn on that
because I have done the work that you
were trying to do with this
visualization I've spent one and a half
two years of my life trying to do it no
this it's it it's a tunnel that ends
nowhere the problem is that
visualization is it looks really good it
doesn't help you need exported data
analysis and you need machine learning
either one of the two I don't want to go
to machine learning okay well Machine
learning is just another one yeah
machine learning we're doing logic here
you start out talking about conflict
direct uh salvers but I I like to avoid
conflict immediately in meetings
there's also this story about the person
who said why are you looking for your
watch under the light here uh when you
lost it on the other street because
there's more light yeah right here and
and you know these are these are tough
fun but I just want to instead of
talking about that I want to talk about
my own experience with sorting I I wrote
a book about sorting and let's say I had
25 sorting methods and and you know then
after I I finished the book uh a year
later I actually was faced with a
problem where I had to do sorting and I
was at a loss because I didn't know
which one to to use but but like you I I
think maybe you I should have had only
three sorting methods or something like
that but but when I looked at it there
wasn't a single one out of these 25 that
I could throw out except bubble sort uh
and and I thought I it's not the bubble
store was something no matter what the
application was I could always do better
than Bulbasaur and and it was
interesting because that was one of the
first
one of the first theoretical results was
that bubble sort was was the optimum
method uh uh right for for a particular
kind of Hardware right based on a
rotating drama okay well all right so uh
but but then uh but but then later on I
found uses for bubble sort not only
because it was a bad example but also
because you know
I could I could apply it to some Physics
problem right so so
um uh it might very well be that when
we're talking about algorithms uh uh
we're going to have to we're going to
have to learn how to live with
with the multiplicity right all right by
the way I'm not pushing uh uh profit
driven satisfiability I I hope that that
message does not get you know I'm not
I'm not saying that I'm saying we might
be missing something else because you
know we that focus on just doing this so
the principle I've been fully on board
more science more understanding than
very good
um maybe in your proposal because you
say uh to do them statistical analysis
about the correlation between families
and solvers but what do we learn about
correlation isn't causation but we would
need to know uh what techniques work why
do they work uh
I'm not done here so yes listen I just
want to show you what we did okay and
then you can
check me out and then I can go home
okay so um with that I started talking
to uh Armin about I don't know a year
and a half ago we met weekly and you
know the first thing that we did he had
the search solver which he felt was
gonna be kind of the way that you can
actually change one thing and then see
how it affects you know performance and
generous things and then when he showed
me the
very complex dependency diagram between
the options meaning if I do this I have
to do that I was like wait a minute wait
a minute how many knobs do we have on
these things okay we have branching we
have uh uh propagation we have conflict
analysis
restarts deletion and so on especially
you know until different things can we
just understand I don't understand them
I don't understand what each is
contributing and whether that so after
long conversations he decided okay we're
gonna have a different prototypical
tabulator okay
um
and the supporting test okay so what we
did
was we wanted to select benchmarks so
they said let's select the ones that
from the 2022 uh competition I said why
they're different you know I mean I
cannot clear correlations from things
that are completely different right so
can we hope they had a table of 2 400
you know all the next parts that have
been collected over the years and they
had some name for a family and so on so
we looked I wanted to get a large
collection of benchmarks from the same
family that might have something in
common with each other it was very hard
to do that but we managed actually we
had uh 12 families but then we
discovered that one of them wasn't
positive because it was arman's family
no nobody solved that so we ended up
with 11 families 14 instances but family
and um we said okay so what are we gonna
check for many things we can check he
said his favorite in processing and
pre-processing I said fine so let's do
that okay so we the students I'm working
with created a database
we need to do a database guys okay we
need to do a difference that collects
the data across years so that we can go
back and say you will run back then when
you thought because I can do the
analysis on it right right now I don't
have that so we have a benchmark payment
we have a
uh what is it we have the solver tables
and the options of the solvers we have
the round table which is I get a
benchmark and a solver an option for the
solver and I know when I did The
Benchmark and I and I saw the results
and it stays there it has a timestamp it
has we can go back and analyze the data
we don't have to do it once you know we
can do it many times we can have a lot
of research going over many years just
looking at data and understanding and
maybe finding something that we didn't
find by just doing the competition
um so uh Armin is a master of naming
things so he came up with this name for
these five options four means no end
processing no pre-processing and uh that
score
then mini said the uh vanilla is like
mini set it does only pre-processing and
pre-processing using bounded variable
eliminations of songs then he had
parfait they're all kind of flavors of
ice cream or something that you look
with your tongue
um in processing but no pre-processing
he wanted to go to more sophisticated
things so he came up with stressiatella
which does in processing and
pre-processing using additional things
like substitution and transitive
deductions don't ask me what these are
because I don't care okay but there are
five things that are independent
supposedly
and now
I need to switch to my
other presentation here
so
so these are the options I have to stand
here now
and uh and so now we're gonna do
the uh
competition plot
and you can see that they're all bunched
up right and in fact
let's think that says 79 is is mini save
and it's only two off from the best one
but this is not honest you know this is
the honest plot here
right
now what I'm saying is I don't believe
that you know cdcl is the
best thing since my spread I mean you
know we need to understand what happened
here you know why do they you know tap
off you know at that point I mean this
is something else going on here but this
is like one bit of information about
what happened right so maybe you're
doing this in this competition but I
didn't see it and maybe I'm just too
lazy and I don't look at what you're
doing
but uh here is kind of another way of
looking at it where
you know all of these are kind of
similar you know one of them could solve
one more than the other but most of them
half of the benchmarks were not solved
in two hours two hours
on on fast you know uh uh you know
server Farms
I'm not defending any of this so then
lots of questions open here to kind of
you know see what's going on perhaps a
more interesting way to look at this is
since the events the the options are
really not what the essentials from each
other let's see
by Family how they are and don't ask me
about how the families are their names
arbitrarily I mean the question about
you know it's hard to do this doesn't
mean we shouldn't try here you see
distinct differences there are some
families that are hard okay Hardware BMC
these are furnace benchmarks the strip
coloring you know look at how many are
unsolved
scheduling school I don't know what that
is
night chess okay then there are ones
that are very easy okay what are the
easy ones my name I don't know what that
is look it says mining it's very easy
um there is this real 2017 we found out
this is about rescheduling in France the
time of life so we don't know exactly
what the formula these are some of the
largest ones they have you know between
a million and a half and three million
variables of them they get sold very
quickly right
um and there are somewhere something
limited you know have you know sold have
not solved
I look at this and I'm very curious what
is going on over here can we now take a
deeper look into what is the actual
formula that we're looking at and why is
you know some of them hard to solve them
one and some easy to solve the other day
we heard about the pigeon pole principle
okay I did fpga error I think years ago
and in fpga routing you get pigeon homes
right you have a channel that can only
have like 10 wires in it and we cannot
attract more than 10 wires switching
hole now we know also from uh complexity
theory that you cannot actually Import
pigeonhole in CNS and you know get any
performance so as a problem solver of
course I don't want to you know encode
it that way I'm going to import that you
know also the volume constraints or
something like that you know that has
counting in it right so from a problem
solvent point to you I picked what would
be the appropriate encoding so the
problem may be difficult for CNS set
that doesn't mean we cannot solve it
right we can then combine you know uh uh
methods you know in order to get the
answer that we want but the fact that it
is actually regular which is very
symmetric right we should be able to
solve it right
um instead of trying to prove what's
impossible which I think is important
but I don't know how to do it I'm trying
to find what is possible and make it
work right and I think now here where
this heritations come and you know it
has about how you do this you know you
take a look at something like this right
and you look at the the trace the
behavior of the series and maybe these
options are not the right ones you know
for this experiment but you know let's
look at this and the theoretation might
kind of look at the instance and say to
the
you know the folder the the the the the
hacker right you say you look they said
someone is doing this you know is there
something about this at a higher level
that we are missing out you know these
are circuits that you know people design
they must have some high level structure
to them is there where they can get that
structured in and then start doing that
correlation uh uh Stefan you know what
I'm saying is not
that uh people have not thought about
this I don't think that we have been
doing it enough in order to kind of
make the theorization that the
practitioners come together as a
theoretician I think they can look at
the uh the structure of the instance
right the the how the uh variables and
clauses are you know organized and so
forth and then look at how the solver is
doing is it learning the right things
maybe maybe you know cdcl is not the
right thing for it maybe something that
says this is what goes to uh nikolai's
idea of you know if you go to the
fastest cell but then we're missing out
some ideas that are you know cannot get
ignored
I am not pushing my thing I'm just
trying to say guys
we have been meeting we have not been
talking
maybe something like this would start a
conversation maybe some maybe the idea
of it's It's hard where is Jacob uh he
invited me several years ago when was
this seven years ago or something like
that and he had the establishing
formulas right
and yes you know they must not be
interesting but they can give you Trends
on these things I think that could still
happen you know we could do that
maybe they can you know we can
it's harder for formulas that come from
applications because you have to know
what the application is and so on so
forth but I think it's worth doing that
because otherwise we're going to
continue finding
what is the set solver behind cbc5
well if you heard
uh the talk from yesterday we now we now
support catacly used to be many sets
okay
and you have a
order message the difference between the
performance
no because most of the the time is spent
in the theory solver but for some
problems it does make a big difference
so for your utilitarian objectives I
have no problem with finding assessor
solver but to understand why it is
solving it I think we need to do
something that's my
foreign
yes I I gave a version of this that
wasn't you know like this at 2014 and
one of my students on the audience he
said you sounded angry I said okay I'll
try not to sound angry this time but I'm
exasperated because I really want to
understand and if I'm not treating the
right literature because it's not
showing up in the places that I look at
you know then then that's my that's not
me but I really think we can do better I
think we can we're ignoring uh looking
at detail like this
um so
well let's do it here so
um if you look now at individual
families you can start finding kind of
the
the the detail of what the soldiers did
and what they did not do and so forth
yes
so although I really like the idea of of
this approach I do think that what
you're currently showing is not that
useful right because this is an example
it's not yeah because we really need to
have families that you can that that is
you get 14 is not enough it's not
specific no no but it's not also you
need to kind of generate it you can see
okay this every time you have a larger
instance it's maybe
10 or 50 percent harder and and so to
have a clear because I know these
families they're typically off the same
size so it's well no some of them are
different sizes yeah some of them are
different sizes listen I'm not
suggesting that I solved the problem
what I'm saying is if you do circuit set
right you can have different circuits of
different sizes and different
compositions they must have something in
common they must have the fact that you
know there is some locality and then
there is no right
um
to just say it can't be done I didn't do
it here because you know we just started
doing this and I don't intend to spend
my life doing this I'm saying that if we
don't think about families
you've classified in the competition
families
and some of these families are bogus
because they just have the name of the
person and then whoever made the
competition rule said you know only 20
solvers per family and then you give
your students together so you have 40
instead of 20. I mean you know I'm not
winning is fine but we need to spend a
little bit more time
um
we choose at most 14 benchmarks we have
a lot of diversity right I think that's
that's also very important for
competition to have a lot of diverse
well the thing is it doesn't explain
things the competition does not explain
things and that's my problem my problem
with the competition is a hotspotch of
things that are completely different and
diverse but when they cannot actually
conclude anything other than
chemical one for you know this one I
want something a little deeper than that
I go back to what the people who did the
phase transition did which is they
defined a family of benchmarks that they
could actually correlate with
performance right
if what I'm hearing from you is that
that's not possible to do then I will
just I would be happy to see such
families right and I but
let's let's also means to come together
so that we can advance our understanding
that's all I'm saying why are these
problems easy to solve why are these
problems not so is it solved you know we
need to do that that answer has not come
through we don't know it's all they it's
all ununderstandable okay I I think we
need to stop here so I just want to put
my last slide which is
there's a lot more detail and you can
look at this slice and by the way I'm
not defending energies this is just
let's do something different that's
that's all this
let me see
okay
science versus entertainment I really
think with all people of knowing science
and we should do it if for no other
reason that we suck at entertainment
all right thank you
[Applause]
thank you
okay so I just wanted to make a comment
since I didn't uh make my uh hostile
comment yet
um but uh actually I I really appreciate
I know you're trying to be provocative
and that's good you know it makes people
think and I also agree that
understanding is great I think it is
unfair to say that we're not doing
science because then you rule out you
know I sit on the systems floor of a
computer science building and everyone
there is Building Systems and now you're
saying you're not doing science because
you're building a system and if you look
at the papers about sat and smt that are
systems papers they do all these things
that you say they say here's a set of
examples that we didn't understand we
tried this technique here's with and
without the technique it's better with
the technique and that now we learn
something right and all these papers
that sat and smt there this is the way
they write the paper so maybe you didn't
read those we've learned a lot about how
this works and that's science now I
agree the competition is not about
science that's more about if I'm uh you
know one of these millions of people
who's using a SAT solver which one do I
pick and the the competition is a useful
Benchmark for helping us see what's the
progress and what should I use and it's
and it's entertaining right right um so
so that's a different kind of science
but I don't think it's fair to say that
we're not doing science
fair enough I the the the only thing I
would add to this is um
okay so I need somebody to tell me one
major idea that happened after I mean
all of this is this based on Mini set I
heard local search right which is kind
of okay and then you know we'll have
this conversation offline would that
help with verification I don't know what
other ideas that have kind of like a
statistically significant improvement
over mini set like you you have credit
cards can can you point out exactly what
that was and then we can then say
celebrate this because this now is a
major uh contribution that works across
yes I mean
well in processing okay
here next here so let's try to do
something like this for click servers
which are much much simpler than sanso
was they only have two or three key
features the instance is a much simpler
and much easier to understand we can
generate large-scalable families in
doing it
um I would suggest that a this is a much
easier place to start looking than to
start developing scientific techniques
but also believe that this is really
really hard and if we can't do it for
Clique then
um why why are we aiming to do this for
saps I mean to answer a very simple
question about a branch why a branching
heuristic in Click solvers works it
requires about a billion problem
instances the experiments cost me about
twenty thousand pounds to run
and this is for a solver that is 50
lines of code on a problem which is
staggeringly simple and sad
well my report to this is when chess
came around
they discovered if we have this adaptive
reacting strategy or confidence that's a
major idea right and they didn't need
billions you know they just I'm looking
for things like that you know that have
that statistic as it there's a
qualitative Improvement you know that is
not so sensitive to many other
variations of you know problems and so
forth so
I I don't see that I'm sorry but I don't
see that
um I think I haven't read the right
papers
you know in this room most of us write
papers for such conferences and and also
participate in competitions and everyone
who tried to submit this over to a
competition knows it or at least I would
say it's fair to say that people doing
queuing web Benchmark instances
so this amount of knowledge to turn your
computer at yourself for the
competitions that works uh maybe with
different parameters on different
management instances it's actually very
valuable you don't usually publish it
because it's dirty uh or maybe it's not
very you can't formulate it nicely but
you know this competition it then you
publish the paper based on something
that you learn by tuning your server for
the competition so I wouldn't say that
competition is not science it's actually
drive science but maybe not in somewhat
obvious way right because when you turn
your solar for the competition we do a
lot of work and understanding why
certain parameters
but during the solar of the competition
I mean I'll go back to linealing you
know which said like 3 300 I think right
with this I mean how can you actually I
mean I understand one thing to do this
this is It's a car race
that you win but if you cannot explain
what was it that made you win you know
in a convincing way not just sold one
more than the other but it makes you
think and later maybe you might not be
able to formalize it right now later I'm
bored now where is the latest
sorry
I'm sorry I
guys I I I know that I'm something like
really uh I'm just saying if we can't
just change it a little bit so that we
can make the data available in a
database you know okay forget everything
I said let's make direct available so
that other people can come in and say
we're gonna do some deep analysis of the
data over time I think that's valuable
let's do it they do it in other times
we're doing the experimental science
here okay sorry for the interpretations
you know my friends but you know most of
this is experimental at this point
yeah so you asked about this qualitative
difference and I here oh sorry yes so
quality difference I think you're right
in asking that so I mean my answer and
of course other people's answers will
differ mine was would be LBD these
literal block distance okay um the glue
stuff
um the local search integration I think
is very interesting also from a
theoretical perspective I think it's not
a slight integration it's not like
pre-solving or something it's actual
real the proper hardcore integration
okay very serious and sophisticated
integration have a look at armin's work
um uh there's the the the the Cuban
Concord which is integration of cdcl
solvers with with low with local head
solvers very serious stuff it's a branch
putting together areas areas of research
and and work of of different types of
solvers and there is um the the the the
bounded uh the bounded variable
elimination which basically puts
together DPL solvers and cdcl solvers
and to one place because it's
effectively a form of dpll in front of
the of the of the South silver and
actually also in the middle if you're
doing it as in processing which is
putting together what used to be called
dpll and cdcr together I think that's
serious and theoretically interesting
and there is this vidification which
which which happens to work very well
and maybe we need to understand a bit
better it's been sort of reinvented a
few times I think that's I mean that's
also the reason why Armin put it into
this happens it's not by chance he did
that I know it's very important so these
are all like except maybe for for
beautification which we we don't quite
understand the LBD which you can ask
Jill in and and and and Simon they will
both tell you that we have no idea why
it works and we still don't understand
okay we're fair enough those will need
to be understood but but these are all
like very significant you put them on
into one such solver they'll be very
close to Kisa
okay
um I think I'm next
um
so um I agree with everything mate said
uh that you know all these advances that
he talked about do
you can see that Improvement and that is
and the Improvement that you see is
significant having said that I think the
spirit in which or the place your heart
is I think it's correct like the point
that you're raising is very valid
meaning that we indeed we don't
fully understand why some of these
techniques work at all for that matter
we still don't understand why Clause
Learning Works
well that's a very valid point
but I think there are two separate
points here one is the understanding
question which is you're right about
that but but to say that advances have
not been made I think that's not a fair
I didn't say that that's it
but you use the word noise so it's so
clear what you meant and there's another
point if you take computer science you
know systems literature somebody else
made this point earlier I think Clark
did you look at the paper you look at
the advances being made from
microprocessors design all the way to
you know operating system any of that
I mean often we don't fully understand
why these systems work right I mean
they're a very complicated heuristics
interacting in complicated ways that we
just cannot understand why why or under
what circumstances they would perform
well right the one difference though I
would say is that in Hardware they tend
to have this very standardized Benchmark
like limp back whatever it is and they
do a huge amount of data collection and
data analysis so I agree with
the kind of the points that you're
raising or maybe the the way in which
you're raising them I think I would
change the tone of that but the points
are valid like the two main points
meaning it would be great to have deeper
empirical understanding but I don't
think we should put it on the theorist
because
um
I really think that the theaters need to
come into the section because no
probably yeah okay anyway enough yeah
thank you yeah let me let me try to also
be brief but so first of all we have the
data from the competitions is always all
available so you have your database and
for example we had last year we had the
anniversary track and so we had all the
benchmarks 20 years of competition
running all the solvers so there you
have so much data that you can analyze
right let me put it in a database that's
accessible to everybody online it is so
everything is available online everybody
here can download it this has been
online since a few weeks after the
competitions it's not that it's it has
to be kind of a community kind of
available I mean
it's all there it's these huge tables
but you can pull off what I'm saying is
it's not easy for you know to make it
accessible so that it's easy for
everybody to kind of share them we don't
need gooeys
[Music]
yeah and the other point is so regarding
your experiment right it's all these
clean families but what you see in
practice from all these applications
there are not so clean and all the
techniques like in processing they
really make a big impact on formulas
that are not so clean that come from all
kind of applications and there's a big
impact there and so that's why you see
that these techniques are impactful on
the competition but not in kind of in
this kind of Clean Bandits but but let's
I guess we we uh are Way Beyond the uh
yeah let's let's have the final I'm
gonna have a question that we promised
and then we'll have to go for a coffee
and talk more okay so hold it
so in our group we spent last five years
trying to do something similar trying to
build statistical and causal analysis
mostly led by mate
I think um I like your proposal but the
issue is that if you just want to do
science we'll be probably able to
understand why certain things work but
there doesn't seem to be a lot of reward
in the community for this understanding
which also seems to be from your
presentation because a lot of times you
hinted that if you understand we are
going to get something the new
heuristics and I want to propose that we
may not get new heuristic we may just be
able to understand that we have gotten
to a good points uh so what's your
proposal to
have enough rewards just for
understanding and thinking about a
future where we will be able to
understand but probably it won't lead to
any new advance in sets of them
I mean for me I don't need any reward
okay I just want to make the people that
come to this meetings the computer
series you know the
um Theory people and the people who like
to call it you know to talk to each
other they're not talking to each other
there is nothing going on so why do we
meet
themselves that's what I'm saying the
facade that you know we're meeting so
that we can have that I mean I I feel
sorry for our Theory friends because
we've created monsters that they cannot
analyze and I'm suggesting a way of
doing that I'm getting pushed back the
families are not clean
so I Lose I'm sorry I mean it's fine
okay okay
so I think it's time to close as the
main organizer of this year is a meeting
since 2018 let me respond by saying that
I'm happy that we're here meeting and
talking about this so let's continue to
do so during the break
[Applause]
excuse me